You
And
I'm out.
Yikes.
Nope.
It's fine.
Don't worry about it.
You gotta fake him out.
I'm out.
Yikes.
gets fucked shadow wizard money gain my hands are sweating what is going on with
my headphones okay you this soda sucks it's a porch digestive health this tastes
like shit I got a ollie pop soda and it tastes like crap
it's all gonna drink it though because I spent money on it
it's calling ollie pop
oh fuck me up
oh
like that I fucking fell in there in the cliff came claims another it was very
good very good
oh
oh I pressed that too late
oh fuck me my timing's all off now
I'm trying to roll forward but I can't because the camera lock and now I'm
trapped it's fine fuck your mom I like how I always I always get so close on
my first try and then I fuck up bye bye have a good one oh have a good camping
trip what the hell that's cool I haven't been camping in so long the vaude will be
like eight hours so don't worry
it's hard cuz you get locked into an animation so you have to make sure you're
just the right amount of way
how'd you cut you cut you
I
hold on
I'm busy oh fuck me
you just fucking slap me what the hell why can't I do this now it was so good
my first run oh no I'm I know I'm not saying
that it'll take eight hours for me to beat this boss I'm telling you I know any
lock back in right any lock back in I'm telling you it's gonna take me eight
hours to do everything else it's gonna be an endurance dream today
oh
I was so close I'm so mad at myself for not getting it the first time I was
expect the hammer yeah they always there's always a second phase usually I
love this game this game makes you so excited because I was like oh I can't
wait to beat your ass and this feels so good after when I do it I'm gonna clap
those cheeks so good market you have no idea just just bend over and take it
market stop fucking me so I can fuck you okay
oh I rolled into that
oh
oh maybe doesn't or maybe it maybe it just it doesn't
maybe can I kill oh look at you can you give me a fucking break bro I'm get
locked in the animation so he gets a free hit every time I do that
I
you know what I'm doing what I'm doing wrong what I'm doing wrong when I'm
getting close to him I'm still using this fucking gravity thing I should be
using the sword I'm fucking stupid it's on me it's not it's it's on me
smash or pass market smash because I'm about to beat his fucking ass to the
ground all right I'm not gonna get cuz once I usually do this he gets a free
one and run behind him do a little I'm right in the noggin
I'm gonna come up close and fucking run away and then I'm gonna run away and then
I'm gonna run away and I'm gonna get locked in my thing so I'm not far away
enough bro bro I'm shitting on myself right now I'm about to fall off this
cliff I wish I could make him jump off the cliff that'd be great
oh I jumped too early and I was too late getting up
I'm out I'm I just scratch my eye I'm scratching my eye
it looks like the kind of passes around STD's
I'm getting hot take off my clothes
it's waiting
okay no I didn't I was taking off my sweatshirt that's it everybody relax
my headphones are tangled and my controllers cable
please whoa I scared me I wish I could play music but I can't cuz YouTube
copyright I'm better when I can play music I usually play my own music when
I fight a boss happy winter oh you must live on an Australia land or something
or European land Western Hemisphere land I don't know no audio audio jungle
hmm
back up back up back up a little might be no
no
No, I'm out, what the fuck am I doing?
Oh I walked into that.
I thought he was going to jump.
No I'm not going to summon anything.
I want to do this by myself.
Sometimes I will like summon to take the aggro off of me if it's a hard boss, usually like
when I played I would literally do mimic tier, have it aggro the mimic tier and then just
blackknife the fuck until the blight fucking killed it.
I rolled into that, rolled too early and I'm still stuck, I'm still stuck, I can get out
of my animations.
I don't even remember pressing that, I'm stuck, I'm stuck, my eye is at you again.
Oh I'm accidentally holding it, ow.
I'm, I, how do you have so much reach?
How do you have so much reach, bro?
Oh I'm doing stuff too late and I'm locked in animations, yeah.
How did I get so close, my first try, because I was locked in, I had the rhythm down, it's
fine, it's fine, guys I promise you.
I'm not, I'm not a trash wizard, I'm a good wizard.
I'm good at this I promise, I'm so good, see?
Liza P taught me well.
Hold on.
I'm busy.
No I was locked in the animation, I was trying to cancel it and I couldn't, no, no, no, no.
Stop, let me breathe.
No, leave me alone.
Ow.
Oh fuck, nope.
I don't know.
Oh, I can't sleep laughing.
Anonymous kicked $3.33.
If Margit had a shampoo brand, it'd be called Cane in Tail.
I hope someone clipped that shit. It was funny as fuck.
Oh, thank you. Thank you for the tip, Anonymous. Thank you.
I don't have my headphones on, so I don't know what was sad, but thank you.
I'm going to look at it right now.
I'm trapped in the game.
I'm locked out of stream elements.
Anonymous.
If Margit had a shampoo brand, it'd be called Cane in Tail.
It almost don't work. Oh, yeah. No, it's fine.
I'm locked out of stream elements.
Anonymous, Anonymous.
I'm locked out.
I'm going to do some stretches. We're just going to get back into the zone. No.
I don't know.
I don't believe it. I mean, it's all railings. What do you mean?
Fuck you.
You guys know, like, I'm decent.
I'm just getting my, I'm getting overeagered. I'm getting greedy.
I'm not getting my timing right.
I don't know.
I'm locked out of stream elements.
I'm locked out of stream.
Okay. I need, where are my airpods.
I need music. I need music so bad.
I need music so bad.
I'm just going to throw on some fucking Rob Zombie.
I remember, I almost dropped something, I was playing as Rinna as a patient right there.
I was playing as Rinna being called the lamb, and I was getting my ass handed to me with one of the bosses.
And so I literally just put on Rob Zombie and I fucking rocked him.
So that's my go to, is I just play some Rob Zombie, or just some dubstep or something.
I don't know, I just have an easier time if I listen to music and I don't listen to the game.
And I can just focus on movement, and so I think the sound distracts me.
Alright, let me just...
I'm thinking about playing sick bubblegum.
The Skrillex remix.
Shibi is the muppet that's operating the model.
The muppet's operating the model.
Dragula, Dragula is also good.
We all know how we're going to die, baby.
Wait, I can't have my model open while I have YouTube open, that's stupid.
Alright, well, ventriloquism.
Alright, I'm in the zone, I feel good.
Please, let me the fucking...
Now I'm getting too into music.
Oh fuck.
Sick bubblegum.
I can't believe I breathed almost on my first try, and then I fucked it up.
And I fell off the map the second time.
Alright, I'm in the zone, I feel good.
I'm in the zone, I feel good.
I'm stuck.
Oh, I just noticed my health.
I'm in the zone, I feel good.
Alright, let's do Dragula.
I'm stuck.
Now I threw it, I didn't know you could do that.
Dig through the ditches and I'm not paying attention to my health because this music is good.
Dragula.
Hi, Boomi.
Boomi, I need your little titties as a little stress ball.
Thank you.
So many apps.
Stream's going good.
I'm in the zone, I feel good.
Fuck.
I got cornered, I knew I was going to get stuck back here.
I'm going to be quiet until I beat him, I apologize.
I can never die, dig through the ditches and burn through the witches of Sam in the back of my Dragula.
No, fuck, I didn't get the stagger.
I got locked into another animation.
I need heal.
And no!
Alright, next song.
Shut me up, my little self-indulgence, let's go.
The bass, the rock, the mic, the treble.
I like my coffee black just like my middle with the bass, the rock, the mic, the treble.
I like my coffee black just like my middle cuz.
Oh, knock me up in a minute, minute, minute, and a fucking minute.
I can't wait for you to knock me up in a minute, minute, and a second.
I can't wait for you to shut me up and make me hit like fuck.
It's fine, it's too far away.
Oh, it was stuck in the animation cuz I accidentally pressed the button.
Shut.
La la la, ooh la la la, ooh la la la.
The whip timed perfectly when you threw it.
Oh, it's funny.
I can't wait for you to knock me up in a minute, minute.
I'm so fucking stupid, I can't wait for you to knock me up in a minute, minute, and a second.
I can't wait for you to shut me up and make me hit like badass.
All right.
I'm getting worse.
It's a great music video.
All right, timed that horribly.
I thought I was gonna stagger him.
I, I...
Whoa, ah!
I'm almost dead.
That's not the one.
Thank you for letting me heal.
Oh.
I'm getting animation locked.
Yeah, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
Declan hide, five finger death punch.
Which is gonna be the magical song, like that's it.
Yes, I'm still in the market!
Fuck off!
I didn't even do a lot of damage.
Ow.
There's a demon.
This is a good run.
I'm just gonna let him kill me.
Are my cats making noise?
What are you guys doing?
I think I'm just drinking water.
What are the other cats doing?
Like nirvana?
Yeah.
Something's in my ass.
Damn, wait on your shoulder.
I just saved your motherfucking life.
Why did I ever feel this pain?
Hey, hey, hey!
No, I missed it!
I'm trying to heal.
Okay, another song.
Maybe I need something at the right BPM.
Okay, locked to DNMO mix.
Are you gonna do anything, bro?
I'm locking in, closing all my tabs, besides the game.
I'm getting sloppy, bro!
Fuck, bro!
I didn't think he was gonna hit me with that.
All right.
Spit.
My slush puppy.
Misfit, misfit, and trouble.
Shit icon, each spit get dicked with the lights on.
That bitch, clean shit icon, each spit get dicked with the lights on.
You guys can't tell how much I'm stimming right now.
My legs are going crazy.
I didn't have to heal.
I'm getting too eager.
I'm getting too eager!
He's like, wow, you're awesome.
Wait, you're dead.
Fuck, I love this song.
I'm getting too angry.
What is up with my timing?
I don't know why I pressed that twice.
I shouldn't have healed until I jumped.
I need to heal.
Don't worry, but I'm not.
I'm just dancing.
I need to do a lap.
I'm dancing to the hum of your fridge.
Fuck out.
I like the lighting.
I like your waitress.
She's pretty hot.
I'm going to do this homeless guy.
I'm putting my clothes back on.
Everybody get up and twerk.
Alright, how have I been looking at chat?
Let me see what you say.
I have a camera mode too.
I'm throwing it back as hard as possible.
My back hurts.
I need a good twerk song.
Bandai Namco.
Let's do that real quick.
How are you not dead?
I need a good twerk song.
No.
Where is this fire coming from?
Where is the child?
Come on down here, lady.
Wow.
Hey, how the awe feels so accurate here about this expression.
It's so weird how weirdly proportioned her body is.
She has such a small head and a huge body.
I call the kids just disappear.
Sorry, I'm trying to kill your mom.
Now she just buffs her mom.
Such a badass shot, though.
Ooh, she's locked in.
Not many men there.
I hate that she just jumps out of the way.
I might just go at her with my sword.
Fuck, I fucked that up so hard.
I can't even direct myself.
I gotta do this shit again.
Indeed.
Racing Moonvale.
Yup, I missed.
It's really just like, oh, because then you have to deal with her second phase.
It's also mostly just like, why isn't there a fucking grace next to the thing that pisses me off to no end?
Because then I gotta deal with these motherfuckers.
I'm gonna kill them so they don't fucking...
I don't like them.
Go away.
I just spam shit and then I gotta like...
Oh my god.
This health I don't need to be wasting.
Yeah, I think the ball route is better.
Fuck off.
I don't even bother.
Sometimes I just want to jump in there and get all crushed.
Alright.
Fuck off.
I can't kill you fast enough.
Actually, I realize I don't have to kill them.
I just have to bop them.
For free?
Can I please drink a glass?
Ha!
Can you chill?
Am I about to get killed?
I love the music in this.
Oh my god.
I fucking need to lock down bitches.
Get out of the way!
Shut up!
No.
Oh my god.
This is annoying.
I was hoping I wouldn't get hit by that.
That's whatever.
Get out of the way, you little bitch.
Thank god.
Her grippers are huge.
I like Lady Dimitrescu's feet because Lady Dimitrescu is hotter.
I'm going to turn into a moon, really?
It's not really cash money of you.
Ow, that actually hurt a lot.
Get over here.
What the fuck was that?
Are you a little staff at me?
Well, this is going to be a long one.
I can already fucking tell.
It's going to take a while to kill her, Nala.
Smash?
Smash or password for Nala?
No, she has too many issues.
I don't feel like dealing with all that.
She's a weird thing with kids.
I'm not about it.
She has 80% magic resistance.
Wow.
Should I be using a different weapon then?
Although she was weak against the gravity.
I'm not.
The gravity did do some damage on her.
Yeah, okay.
Well, I guess we'll...
Yeah.
We'll figure it out.
Oh, it's just a portal that they come from.
That's nifty.
That's true.
I'm just throwing rocks at her.
All right.
Then I'll kill her with the sword and I'll switch to magic.
I'll switch to the gravity.
I'm not going to use any of my ashes at all so I can conserve using them.
I might do a jellyfish to poison her, perhaps.
Hold on a moment.
Hi, Fia.
What are you doing, little girl?
Just trying to help my lamp.
You're just getting it stuck to my chair.
Can you hear her little claws just going...
Sorry, I need to calm down and pet my cat.
What are you guys sticking your head in the trash for?
I just remember to pay them after you beat the boss.
Fia.
The deathbed companion.
Come here, Fia.
I want to pick you up.
Fia.
How well?
How's it going?
Oh, look at your little face.
With your little pink nose.
With your little eyes.
You're getting a little round, lady.
Are you coming a little chunker?
I don't know.
Fia kind of looks like a ferret for a meerkat.
I had to post that picture of her sitting up on her hind legies and she looked so goofy.
She looked like a little meerkat.
Oh, shoulder.
I love a round kitty.
What do you mean?
I don't want her to be chunky.
She needs to be my little small gal.
I don't want her to get in, like, having health issues or something.
I remember my friend's cat had this thing about shoving its face in a girl's shoes and just walking around like that.
That's so funny.
Fia likes to stick her toys in my shoes and hang out.
I don't know why.
She also just likes to lick my feet.
She woke me up and scared me because she was licking my feet while I was sleeping.
The other day, I was scared the crap out of me because it was early morning.
I think I had fallen asleep on the couch or something from watching TV.
Sometimes if I can't sleep, I'll move to different places to sleep.
I woke up and she was licking a nibble in my feet and I was like, ah!
She's something.
She also really liked when I got my toes done.
Her and Boomi were sniffing my feet.
I'm gonna fuck where it'll be us go.
All right.
I'm so tired of this lady.
It's the steps.
It's the steps that's annoying.
I wish she was more straightforward.
All right, we're two-handed in it.
We're looking for one of the first bitches.
Ow.
Unlock.
There's the next one.
I hear you.
Where are you, child?
Here.
There's a lot of people singing right now.
I need to unlock.
I kind of want to hide over here until she shoots her little fucking thing.
I've actually never seen her do it.
Oh, they just get turned into gravestones?
Oh, my God.
Fia is actually sniffing and licking my feet right now.
Stop.
She heard me talking shit.
Are they all golf chicks?
Oh, God, my nose is itchy.
Ow.
Get back down here, lady.
Look at my heel.
I need one more.
I love my fucking knocking kids out.
I'm going to turn into fucking gravestones.
Oh, that did not save me.
I'll tell you that much.
Should have used the Wonders Psychic for that.
Ow.
Ow, I walked into that one.
I didn't know she was an Abbey Shepherd sheep, you viewer.
Do you have a cat that likes to get high after mineral ice smell?
What?
Like the water?
Oh, I need to get out of the way first.
Oh, no, that's a shield.
Oh, no, I'm stuck.
It's fine.
Okay, it's not fine.
No, I was trying to heal.
Oh, I hate Rinala so much.
What's another spell like the gravity one that I can use on her?
What's another spell like that?
I need something long range, but the thing with the gravity spell is that nothing you have,
but I can go get it.
The thing is that, I regret what I was going to say.
Oh, my, I almost missed again.
Making my way downtown, walking fast, faces past, and I'm homebound.
I've been nothing with a strength deck, so that's fine.
I did, I used, I can't even remember what I beat her with.
I think I beat her with the Halo Scythe, or did I beat her?
Wait a second.
I'm going to do it one more time, and then I realize I should probably upgrade my Glenstone staff.
I mean, my Muterite staff.
I didn't do that, I only upgraded my, can I upgrade my staff?
I can upgrade my staff, right?
Again, I've never been a sorcerer, so I don't fucking know anything.
Fia, I can feel you grabbing my chair.
Da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da.
Fuck, fuck, fuck off.
Yeah.
I feel like I'm in prison.
Oh, I was hoping it wouldn't hit me.
What am I doing?
Ow.
Stop hitting me, they're stupid fucking books. Oh god, everybody's spitting fire.
I can't tell where she is, is everybody singing the same fucking song? Ow. What? I swear, I already did. Wait, did I miss something?
Did I? Did I? Did I already kill enough and I didn't even fucking realize? I don't even... I don't... I don't fucking know, bro.
I feel like it glitched. I feel like it just glitched. Yeah, she fell for like a second and then she got right back up. That was weird. I thought that was me, but I don't think it is.
Oh, now you come down.
Okay. Stop, you fucking little bitches. Oh my fucking god, dude, I hate Renala. She's the most annoying... I beat her so easily the first time because I just... I think I know what I'm going to do.
I think I know what I'm going to get.
I don't know why her fight music sounds like a good idea.
Yeah, anime, OST. To me.
Talisman does make me do double damage. I just skimmed my ass.
Oh my god. Ah, I didn't mean to do that one.
Fabulous.
I am using the meteorite staff. What? Have I not been using it the entire time? I got it. Yeah, no, I'm using it.
I know what I'm going to go get.
One moment.
Wait, I don't think I'm able to scale.
Fuck, yeah, I need to play it more.
I need something that builds.
Maybe if I... I need to poison her or I need to scarlet rot her ass.
Yeah, the Talisman moves. I don't.
Which one is that? I know it's the one with the heads on it, I believe.
There are some arrows. No, bro, what? No.
With what bow? I don't even have a fucking bow. Jollyfish can poison? Alright, true.
Serpent bow. That's true.
But I feel like the Jollyfish will just get fucking, yeah, dragon breath, but you need faith for that.
I think I have one, aren't I? Okay.
You can grab the poison mist ash, but I can't apply the ash to my sword.
Okay.
I can get the neck, yeah. But like, I don't want to...
I feel like it would be easier if I honestly just tried to brute force this.
Hmm.
Because I don't think it'll help too much.
If anything, I'll get the medallion, the boost sorcery.
Breathe in, blast, Talisman.
Oh, I forgot where he's like, in her Talisman.
Okay.
Because honestly, the sword seal is helpful, but it's also fucking me at the same time.
The dragon crest shield could offset the damage. No.
Is there a medallion that reduces damage taken?
Take your ash, Talisman.
That connection.
It's not a great job.
That's true, that would produce the magic taken.
Good morning.
That's one of the runes there.
Yeah, I was thinking about the graven school, Talisman.
I just have to remember where to get it.
Plus 1 million in the staff of Blossom, Night Comet, which is a lot of money.
Yeah.
Yeah, because I just have to kill the room bear.
So I'll go and get that.
And then...
I'll go and get that.
Well, it's either like, do I want to boost my own or do I want to?
It's probably better if I actually negate.
Uh...
Where is that?
Wait, no, what am I doing?
It's in the Weeping Peninsula.
Where in the Weeping Peninsula is it?
I need a map.
Uh...
Damn it, I fell asleep again.
It's fine, it's not like I haven't been streaming for like hours.
Fuck, what number did I say it is?
I don't know which way I'm fucking going.
I'm assuming it's 2.
Where did I put my 1?
Hey, I wish I would show you when you put your own fucking markers.
Okay, where's this fucking bear?
I don't care about no damn goblins, where's this fucking bear?
There it is.
What? No, that's not a bear.
That is the demigod thingy.
It's demihumanlady.
She drops like a staff if I recall.
Where am I?
It's over here.
Where's this fucking bear?
Left side?
Over here?
Bear, where for art thou, bear?
Is it that big ass bear that scratches the tree?
Oh my god, that scared the absolute shit out of me.
Unnecessarily loud.
Ugh, I'm irritated so you guys are gonna die.
You gonna run away?
Bitch.
Oh no, it's just a trap.
They just laid shit out for me and I fell for it.
I'm just saying that it's right over around here and it's not.
I'm just gonna stay up here for a second.
No, I am, cause I'm like there is a fucking dungeon and I can't remember and it's this big ass white bear.
I believe, or just like white one.
I don't remember.
I'm not spell drained.
No, I'm not.
Perfect.
Wait, they did it.
They went to the school of sorcery. What the fuck is this other guy telling me?
First light of the torches. Do I have to really do it? No, this isn't it.
Do not recall it being difficult.
I don't remember.
Inside the earth bore cave.
Where is the fucking earth bore cave?
It's showing that the cave is right around here.
Oh my god, I almost jumped across that.
Where is the earth bore cave?
Oh, maybe it's below.
Yeah.
Oh my god, I almost jumped across that.
Where is the earth bore cave? Is it? Oh, maybe it's below.
Yeah, right over here.
This has to be a cave over here.
Thank you.
Oh, nifty.
Oh.
This is fun.
Why is this rat so strong?
Alright, where is this fucking bear?
I forgot that this little thingy drops you.
Probably shouldn't just be dropping really nearly,
but I'm just kind of just trying to speed around this.
Bear. Oh, thank you.
Oh, you're way stronger than I thought you'd be.
Oh.
Fuck.
Can I get up there?
That is a good thing.
Fucking slapping me one, trying to drink.
Killers are killed by a bear.
I don't have to have my own kind in this cave.
Huh.
Nice try.
Oh.
It was a pickled turtle.
This is awkward.
What are you doing, Fia?
Why are you using my footrest as a cat scratcher?
I feel like how it's the whole fucking boss thing.
I know.
I'm stuck in the bear.
Fuck.
She died already. Jesus Christ.
The crazy part is the room bear isn't even the strongest one.
Bear is angry because I came into its home.
I mean, you did just come into it.
Well, it was sleeping and I just kind of walked in and attacked me first.
Like, let's be real.
Fuck.
Cool. All right, we did that.
Fia, can you please stop chewing on my headphones, darling?
Can I, can you give this back to me?
Thank you.
What's up?
Give me a little kiss.
Feels like a doll.
Fader arc? Oh my God.
Fia, you wanna come snuck?
Yes.
Hmm.
Let me do a little bit more research.
She says that she's just weak to bleeding and I'm like, well, I tried that.
I tried to make her bleed.
It didn't work out.
It works for her if I can like spam on her for a little bit.
Honestly, I need more, I need more golden seeds.
So I can have more health.
Fia, can you please, what are you doing?
Come here.
What are you doing?
Everything's unbending.
What, is that moving?
There's nothing around. I don't like regularly stare at stuff.
What are you doing?
You leaving me?
Do what you must.
Hmm.
I don't think
I'll have enough.
You said that the other talisman
is around here.
You're the debate parlor, right?
I believe.
I can't really do anything with that because if I take off riding in Sore Seal,
then I'm not going to be able to wield
the Moon Veil.
I thought I was going to miss that.
What happened again?
I'm just giving my computer a little breaky poo.
So you can get him up at Sheeby.
Up at Sheeby making me feel
ways I've never felt before.
She's got a nice one.
At least I look nice.
That was a sick nasty outfit.
It poo.
Oh brother, this guy stinks.
And your character looks nice in game.
Thank you, thank you.
Just so I don't accidentally do shit.
My mother died.
These books fly everywhere.
You scratch my nose.
Ah, that's a fucking thingy.
Sorry.
Oh, boomy, why?
I can't see, boomy.
Okay, boomy, it's fine if you walk now,
because now I can just spam killing her.
Die, die, die, die.
Ah, back up, back up!
Ow.
Ow, I'm stuck, I'm stuck, I'm stuck!
It's because I'm fucking locked on.
Oh my.
Boomy, could you please move?
You also were sitting in front of my screen.
As punishment, I hold you like a baby.
But you like being held like a baby.
I don't mind my boy.
Scratchy your chin.
No.
Sorry, I'm busy holding my son like a baby.
Because that's what he is, he is a baby.
He's the babyest baby that ever babyed.
He's making like airplane ears while I'm petting him,
it's kind of funny.
Big time attention hours.
Help me step up it, I'm stuck.
No, you can't leave.
It's my time, it's my time to snuggle you.
Mercy?
Scared the shit out of me.
That just terrified, oh my god.
Oh my, I'm so happy I wasn't doing anything
because I would have thrown my controller across the room.
Oh my god, everybody, everybody says hi.
Hello.
What was that?
My autonomous dog.
What? How does it do, is it like a sound board?
You know, you know, the little like.
Oh, like the thing, yeah, the like saying.
Yeah. Oh, I thought that was you.
No, seriously, it does sound like me sometimes.
Come on, let me show you.
Play me a song.
Play you a song?
Yeah, yeah.
Happy birthday to me.
That was gorgeous.
Everybody clap, clap for Mercy everyone.
My chat is very impressed.
The resemblance is on candy.
So it's between you and the little music note thingy.
Oh, I'm dead.
Especially if you shake it, you can like shake it off.
Oh my god.
What the hell, I want one.
It's like, it's like.
Here, you know what to do.
New suggested gift, that's one of those.
Automaton, is that what it's called?
Automaton.
Automaton, that's cool.
Mercy sounds like an automaton.
That's what somebody said.
I mean, I do like it's uncanny.
Mercy's just screaming in my chat.
That's what's happening if you just come in.
Sorry, I saw you were on the open mic and I went,
can I troll Shibby?
That's so scary.
I was so like, I was like locked in, like thinking about,
okay, what do I have to do next in this game?
And then it heard.
Thank you.
I needed to laugh because I'm starting to get angry.
Oh my god.
Well, how are you doing?
I'm doing great.
How are you?
How's Elden Ring?
Elden Ring's fine.
Have you ever played Elden Ring?
No, I'm not ready for souls like yet.
You're not ready?
Yeah, I think the motion sickness would actually get to you.
Yeah, it would be tough.
That sucks.
But yeah, it's going well.
Are you streaming today?
I am.
Later though, like in like three hours?
Two or three hours?
Roughly three hours, yeah.
If I'm still around, I'll wade right into you then.
If I make it that long.
Yeah, no problem about it.
Sorry to disturb.
I just wanted to...
No, no, you did not disturb.
Azura did the same thing yesterday.
I know, I don't know why.
I'm not hearing people come in when they like go into the discord.
It's funny.
It's only in this channel.
It doesn't work.
I wonder why.
Anyways, sir.
I have a lovely surprise.
Thank you.
No problem.
The dark yandere, everybody.
Oh my God.
I love you.
Love you too, hearts.
Huggy.
Make sure you beat the bad guy or the good guy.
I don't actually know if you're the good guy or bad guy in Elden Ring.
I'm both, essentially.
Yeah, that's it.
I can be either.
Oh my God.
My chat is sending their love.
I love your chat too.
Hello, Hera.
Be nice.
I mean, actually, I think she'd be supposed to be the one to be nice.
Never mind.
I've been beating them all day.
Yeah.
Torturing them with my Elden Ring gameplay.
I'm sure you're great.
You are the resident, one of the residents.
Uh, souls like.
I'm sure it's fine.
It's fine.
She'd be extremely serious.
Oh yeah, and happy 4th of July.
Thank you.
Happy Canada Day for a couple days ago.
It's so funny how that are independent days or whatever they are.
Old or like the days of each other.
It's always funny.
Do you get fireworks?
We get fireworks.
I think they're doing fireworks around the 6th.
Oh, okay.
That's kind of late.
Yeah, they like, it's like my town desert or whatever.
And so they're going to be blown off right by my house.
I feel like because I, and it's going to be.
I'm wondering if I'm, I have to check the time if I'm streaming at that time.
Cause then somebody said, I should do ASMR.
You're being shelled by heart artillery and your mommy is trying to rush you to safety.
Wait, that's a good plot.
What the heck?
I know.
I'm like, actually.
Perfect.
Actually, that might work.
That's not just might work.
No, that's really good.
One of my viewers came up with it.
Gosh, viewers have like the best ideas.
They really do.
Yeah, it's mine now.
Actually, I came up with it.
Sorry guys.
It's all my idea and my little Muppet brain.
That's where it came from.
Did you see my Muppet form yet, Mercy?
I did.
I noticed I was like, oh my gosh, you could actually put your model behind the Muppet because it's your hand.
Yeah.
Somebody did such a good job.
I love it.
It looks really good.
It looks so seductive.
I know.
I'm a little seductive Muppet.
Would you put your hand up her?
They already said they would make me into one of their socks.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
They're also saying I'm a furry because I'm a Muppet.
I don't know how that works.
I don't know.
You were already a furry.
You're a bunny.
I'm a kemama mamimi.
That's like, you know, just one step away from furry.
I'm sorry.
I'm in denial.
I'm not accepting it.
Don't die.
No.
It's okay.
I'm joking.
I'm choking.
I'm choking on your love.
Okay.
That's a way to phrase that.
But yeah, you're already furry.
I'm sorry.
At this point, you're probably, you know, you're probably like so close to like the
saw, you know, the jigsaw, like fan fictions and fan arts.
Excuse me.
No, she calls it like this.
She sees them.
No, she has an eye patch on.
She doesn't know what she's seeing.
I'm partially blind.
Oh my God.
Am I projecting?
No.
Of course.
Oh my God.
All right.
Is Vila just a bunch of furries?
Are we all just furries?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll accept it if I'm not alone.
Yeah.
Look, look at me.
Look at Amy.
Heck, we even have icy.
There's a cuttlefish.
That's a scaly.
That's true.
Is that a scaly?
I think scaly's are reptiles.
Oh, shit, really?
Wait, why did I know that?
Fuck.
Mercy, how are you furry?
Is there isn't an animal?
Are you not saying that humans are not animals?
She has a point.
Oh my God.
Okay.
I'm going to attempt to continue with my boss.
I love you.
I'll leave you be now.
I love you too.
Bye, Mercy.
See you later.
I just wanted to spook you.
Oh, he works.
I call you furry, I guess.
No.
My.
I love her.
She's great.
She's scared of shit out of me.
All right.
Don't go.
You'll see her later.
You know, she streams at 11 Eastern time.
She'll be around in a couple hours.
Yep.
Yeah.
What was that?
I didn't ask.
I realized I didn't run because it hits the second pillar over there.
You see where the point of my like bounces off of that then goes to the right.
And I was still close to the right when that happened.
I thought I was storming outside, but it's just the game.
I think.
Oh, wait.
No, if people throwing off fucking fireworks.
See, it bounces off that one.
And now I got a ride.
No.
Sorry.
It's the first one that bounces off of.
Wow.
All my rooms that I got back.
I wasn't.
No, I.
I'm not going to go to the boss after it hits me and knocks my health in half.
I'm just going to kill myself.
I'm just kill it because I don't like you have to make sure I have to make sure I'm at full
health.
I was just going to work otherwise, you know.
Oh, I'm hungry.
Ting.
Why isn't there?
I know there's a fucking.
It's like right here is a grace when you beat her, but yeah, we're doing the moon veil only
strat up until I get her to her second phase.
I'm getting fucking got by books.
Ow, ow.
You can't.
Go in the middle of them because they will fuck you up.
Fuck off.
You fucking books.
Sleep tight.
Shut the fuck up.
I'm down here, lady.
I'm missing.
Thank you.
Okay.
I need to see where she's going to throw that.
This won't break.
Yeah.
Okay.
Bitch.
Bitch slapping children.
Oh my God.
That guy scared me.
Bitch.
I missed.
I still smells like burnt popcorn.
I wanted to break her before she did that little move.
Unlock.
She's over there.
Fuck.
Where is it?
Ow.
I'm getting got by books.
Yeah, everybody just watch as I kill your mom.
Die.
Why are you hitting graduates?
Because I want to.
They're dumb little children.
Oh my God.
Oh, I'm so sick of you.
What?
Say it to my fucking muppet face.
Fucking end you.
I'd rather fucking fight Radon at this point.
This is just annoying.
It's a hard not life.
Knock.
I said not life.
It's a hard not life for us.
All my cat's food is going off instead of kibble.
We get treats.
Oh my God.
Would you really rather fight Radon?
I don't know, actually.
At least I could be on fucking torrent.
This person was like me and definitely ran off.
I want to punch the blood stain.
Oh no, that's they died that way.
You look pretty badass while you were doing it though.
You got Uchigatana or the Naga something.
I'm not a furry.
Oh my God.
I'm so sick of this song.
Oh, perfect.
Oh, I miss.
Die.
I'm locked on you.
Get down here.
No, not you.
No.
Sweetings.
Little Ting.
Oh, books.
Oh, fire.
Books are my one enemy in this game now.
I keep missing you.
I can't.
There's too many people to focus on.
It's hard for the camera to lock.
Fuck off.
Oh, fucking child landing on me.
Get down with your bad self.
Fucking slugs.
Your feet are big.
Ah.
Where is this one?
Alright, she is.
Not too bad.
They are going to fall.
Oh, fucking books.
I feel like Art of Muppets should be wearing a shroud.
It would be funny.
Jesus Christ.
That would be hilarious, actually.
Oh, why was that taking forever?
Do I have to go up close to you?
Okay, I realize it's better to roll towards her.
I'm running out of stamina, though.
No, I'm coming through.
Do I have to click it?
Oh, fuck you.
Fucking bitch.
Ow.
No, no, I don't want to die.
I don't want to die.
I just get the timing right for that one.
Oh, no.
I'm attacking you.
I don't care about any of that shit.
Nope, nope.
You're mine.
Hold on.
Fuck off.
Oh.
Stop it.
Enough.
You're done, Manala.
Sit.
Get fucking...
Yeah.
First try.
100% first try.
I think one of that only took me like seven tries?
Eight tries, maybe ten?
I don't know.
That'll go through close for loose change.
Yeah, I'll be right back.
Hey.
Me.
I need shit for that.
I'm a gamer.
Pulling those dodges off.
I'm telling you.
A pee really helps me with Eleanor because I would not be able to do this normally.
Normally I could not get dodges right and I literally would just either cheese a boss
or I just spam shit.
But I'm actually pretty proud of myself that this run I am actually like dodging.
I would be parrying too if I was doing that sort of build but I'm not.
I know I'm no gamer but I'm not like painfully bad.
But I'm not painfully bad.
Perseverance.
That's my word.
That's my word this year.
Perseverance.
I'm entertainingly bad.
I'm not a gamer at the end of this playthrough.
A true gamer.
Sick.
You're kind of weird.
You're just a bit weird.
Is it audio skipping for anyone else?
Is it audio skipping?
I don't know.
I went through a lot.
I can't really lock her for it.
Okay.
Let me do...
Should I do more intelligence?
Yeah.
I feel like that's good.
Because then I won't need Radigan's Scar Seal to fucking wield this.
I don't think.
Oh I need Strength and Dex.
Oh you're right.
Because I need 18 and I need 12.
Fuck.
I wish I read that before.
It's fine.
What does her green do?
I don't know.
I don't have it yet.
It doesn't really matter.
Yeah.
It's just two more levels.
In fact.
Oh shit.
I haven't been doing any crafting or nothing.
Do I need to go somewhere to do her rune?
I don't have to.
Right?
Oh.
I don't have to.
Yeah.
Is it Ronnie's wedding ring in there?
I need a larvae.
That's right.
I would need a larvae.
Larva.
Larvae.
I don't know what the fuck I'm saying.
That's true.
I could use the Remembrances.
Because I don't really care about the items.
The only item I care about is Radon's bow.
Because I'm going to need that for farming.
I might as well do that now then.
Wait.
Do I have to go to the fucking...
I was like, where is it?
I might as well just go here first.
Do I only have...
I don't...
You're going to laugh at me, but I thought this was a helmet.
And I just realized it was Ronaldo.
I like how I just went past it.
And I was like, oh, where is it?
It's right fucking there.
Yeah.
Because what's hers?
Wait.
Before I do hers, does hers give a spell?
I don't want her funny hat.
I don't care about her funny hat.
I hate her hat so much.
Hers does give a spell.
Is it?
It's the comet, isn't it?
I'm not going to do hers then.
It's the moon bomb.
Oh, I never fucking even use that.
Never mind.
Yeah, that's right.
I recall now.
I think I got her funky little hat instead.
Yippee.
Her staff is good.
I don't really care.
It's one of the best staffs, but it isn't the best staff.
My staff's fine.
I can always get a better one late game.
Her staff is good, but what am I doing?
I'm looking fashionable.
That's what I'm doing.
What am I doing?
I totally forgot what I was going to do.
Oh, no.
Okay, I don't need that.
So now I can stop fucking myself over with that.
So where is the graven?
Damn.
Look at her feet.
Look at her soles.
She's a little dimple on her foot.
Interesting.
Anything else that I can see?
Oh, all right.
I hate your...
Your weirdly proportioned body is so disturbing to me.
It is generally uncanny valley and it bothers me so much.
Oh, wow.
Look who's that.
It's Radigan.
Fascinating.
So now we're going to get the school.
I'm looking at her feet.
Don't worry about it.
Don't worry about your own feet because I'm covering your feet.
Probably also...
There's another wonder physics.
Okay, okay, okay.
Not my grippers, madame.
Your grippers are not safe.
Exit the parlor.
There's an illusory wall.
Attack the bookshelf.
Oh, before the stairs.
For the stairs.
This one.
Where is it?
Oh, it's this one.
Sick, we got Comet.
All right, where is the ladder?
This is not the ladder you climb.
Follow the wall to a room with the ladder.
Oh, this one.
Sorry, I just wanted to break that.
Time for jumping.
I want to jump.
Do I have to go down?
That's a creepy little hole.
Let me go this way first.
There's nothing there.
Okay, we go down the creepy little hole.
Be wary of group.
I don't see anything.
Is it the jars?
I guess it is the jars.
How do I get out of here?
Walk with me, little jar.
Oh, never mind.
Now, now, fuck, shit.
Excuse me, pardon me.
She's in the walls.
Yeah, fuck, now I'm a heavy load.
Why am I going to fat roll?
Are you serious?
That's so stupid.
Actually, I don't really need the spells right now.
My microphone is in my face.
I'll put that back on.
It's still a heavy load.
Okay.
That's better.
Got one grim difference.
Broke a sand.
I know.
Just drop the shield.
Oh, yeah, what the fuck?
I have the shield on.
I need that shit.
I need those right now.
Now we big chillin'.
Okay.
So, we got Morgan, Godric, and Rinala.
Now we just need to...
I believe I have to go rest at a side of grace outside of this, right?
Or does this count?
Oh, fuck, do I get out of here anyways?
No.
Oh, my God, he's scared the fuck out of me.
Jesus Christ, he's scared the shit out of me.
Oh, I'm alive?
Oh, my God.
I just got a fucking shiver from that.
Okay, if it's redawn time, it's redawn time.
Fuck, I have to go really far.
I just don't like the noises they make.
It freaks me out.
Yeah, they do do way too much damage.
I don't know the type of damage that they do.
I don't know why I teleported all the way over here when I shifted down over here.
We'll see if it works, and we'll see if we can fuck up redawn.
Let's do it.
What's up with the music?
My favorite place to be.
Okay, look how beautiful sunny skies.
It's really gorgeous out.
Got a dude here.
I'll say hi.
What do you got?
I haven't even been using any of that stuff.
I haven't been crafting shit.
I haven't been doing anything.
I'll do all that later.
When I get to DLC, I'll focus on getting a lot.
I'm just trying to get to DLC right now.
What the hell?
There's a casual golden seed.
Alright, let's keep going.
I want to be known before I go to sleep.
Imagine Muppet should be killing the bosses of the sound clip.
Miss Picky Karate Choppy Kermit!
Has been amusing me all stream.
That is hilarious.
Thank you, Oregon.
Have a good sleep.
Oh my god, that just made me chuckle.
There's a lot of puppies around here.
I don't want to anger the puppies.
I like how this one, the bird, that's not a death bird,
but the bird just kind of sits there and chills.
Sneaky?
Sneaky, sneaky, be careful.
Are they chilling?
Yeah, I know how terrifying they are.
Sick.
I don't have any sacred tears, right?
I thought I did when it said,
Oh, you want to use a sacred tear?
I'm like, oh yeah, sure.
I need 52 intelligence for that.
Jesus Christ.
Alright, well.
Let's ride and avoid shit.
Where is it?
There it is.
Oh, that already fucking took out Torrent so fast.
Alright, nevermind.
I wanted to get away from the fire,
because I knew I was going to die.
It's fine.
I got that.
I've always been kind of confused by that.
Why is that?
Oh, there's a portal here.
It cannot be used now.
Damn, fucking Torrent is getting God right now.
Oh, Torrent, please.
Oh, come on, Torrent.
You got this, Torrent.
Come on, Torrent.
It's fine.
Oh, well.
This will be fun.
Hey, nice.
How did the...
Oh.
Who's manning this trebuchet?
I just want to talk.
I came up all the way here to kill you.
I thought this is where Red Main Castle was.
Something near me?
Oh, fucking bat.
What's up, bitch?
Can I launch myself back?
That'd be funny.
I want to launch myself.
Yeah, that'd be nifty.
No, we both can't attack each other.
Damn it, I thought I could jump right before, but there's a little thing right there.
Did you sit at an altar?
Apparently, Volcano Manor doesn't count.
How many runes did I lose?
Can somebody tell me?
Actually, I can tell myself.
I am blocking how many runes I have.
It probably doesn't matter.
I don't really care that much.
Yeah, four to five K.
It's not a big deal.
Okay, yeah, that doesn't count.
Let's go back.
Try to leave the fucking manor.
Well, frick!
Sorry, rubbing my fucking ears, because the headphones itself don't hurt.
It's just that when I'm wearing my glasses with them, they press a little bit.
It's like a little headdent.
I have dents about my fucking ears.
Now, how the fuck am I supposed to leave this place?
There's a grace here.
I can't fucking remember.
I wish I had Bloodhound Step, because then I would just attach that to a dagger and fucking go wherever.
That's where it came from?
No.
Sure.
Let's go wherever this leads us.
There's a lot of stuff here.
What do the people have to say?
Detour ahead?
Are you wearing a hole?
A vision of a hole?
Oh.
I found the hole.
I found it.
Didn't expect a hole.
Grass.
Alright, he's fighting something.
Isn't this where...
Wait a second.
This looks mighty familiar.
Isn't this where you fight late?
A question mark?
At some point?
I don't know.
No?
It's a different place?
It's a no-car...
Oh yeah, you're right, you're right.
Oh.
Who the fuck is here then?
Let's find out.
Oh, it's...
Oh, fucking Jesus Christ.
This is fun.
Ow.
Actually...
No, I'm going to roll into that.
No, I don't want you to be grabbing his little hands.
How am I supposed to...?
Oh, I was hoping it wouldn't be able to hit me.
Oh fuck, you're over here now.
Ain't that nice?
Am I dead?
I gotta be dead now.
Grab my little body.
There really isn't a whole lot of little snakes.
I hate that they're called abductor.
I thought it was going to be called abducator.
I thought everybody was joking.
Alright, well...
You gotta say hello.
Now I know what to expect.
Look at this little guy.
They're so cute.
Truly.
Well...
Since there's a hole there...
I should probably get a fucking flashlight.
Can I go around it?
No?
Yes?
Can I go down there?
Alright, well...
If you insist.
What are they weak to?
Not that I have anything.
When you're first doing a playthrough and you grab everything
and you do fucking every little thing,
you have so many swords and weapons to play with.
I'm like, ah, they're weak against this?
Bet, and then I fucking pull that out.
Did they fight them all the way over here too?
I'm confused.
Duck people.
The hole is the way out.
Alright.
Try lightning.
I don't have any lightning.
Cough, cough, cough.
No, no.
Let me out.
I literally dodged that.
What did I mouth you, girl?
Merging up doctors?
They're weak when they open?
I didn't know they were full of snakes.
They're just a lot of little grabby hands.
Let's see how they do with the regular magic.
I know someone said grass, but they're like lily pads.
Surprise! It's snakes!
What?
I wish there was friendly fire on these fucking bitches.
That would be great.
No!
Don't do it, you fucking whore.
I swear to God.
No!
I'm tired of this, Grandpa.
What I usually do is I usually get them trapped.
How did you get up there, bro?
How did you get up there?
Oh, perfect.
Well, never mind.
Come on!
Even if I got up there, how are they able to hurt me?
I didn't know I could throw it upwards.
Muppet? Yeah, one of it.
You're a muppet.
Boy, you built like a muppet.
Excuse me, sir.
Boy, you built like a baked bean! A baked bean!
This is annoying.
If there was one of them, that would have been fine.
But the twins makes it a little bit more tricky.
Stop it!
And then it becomes fucking impervious.
And so it's a waste of my fucking stuff.
Can I see?
See, it can grab me from here.
Oh God.
Jesus.
This is great.
Can I have a moment?
Oh God.
What the fuck, bitch?
Oh, what the fuck, bitch?
No. No.
No.
It looks like I can't get out of here.
Why are you talking like that?
Is your E button broken?
Again, with the homestuck speech.
You're giving me a stroke.
Sadly, yes.
Why don't you just pop the key off and try to fix that?
I'll buy you.
I'm back in 2005 and I hate it.
I know, I feel like I'm reading MySpace.
Should I?
They probably won't do shit with the lead.
Alright, fuck it.
Oh.
I was actually working, so I will continue to do that.
I'll focus on one.
It's just hard to keep an eye on the other one.
Yeah, I don't know why you just don't copy-paste ease.
That's a good point as well.
Well, that is annoying in like the middle of a sentence.
I'll be here or something.
Okay.
Alright, it doesn't matter.
A little fire never hurt nobody.
Visions of hole.
Chapped humps together to give him an E.
That's funny.
I can't even read that.
What?
Alright, let's focus on one.
I'm gonna focus on this one.
I was drinking!
This will take a while.
I apologize in advance.
I just hate it when I have to walk places and do the same fucking thing over and over again.
Just drop me in front of the thing.
That's all I ask.
Are you drinking during a fight?
Kinda fucked myself as well.
That's a good point.
Let me try to see if the jellyfish will take off aggro, but I highly doubt it.
I'm wondering which one.
I have the skeleton militiaman ashes.
I have the jellyfish.
And then I have the wolves.
I'm asking the triggers.
I should grab early.
It's funny because I instinctively want to do that as if I'm gonna wiggle out.
Should I grab the jellyfish?
Oh, master triggers!
Do it!
Oh, it kinda worked.
No, do it again.
Guys, I don't think this is working.
Guys, I think I have blood loss.
I'm starting to forget regular sheevee and getting used to muffin sheevee help.
It's kinda weird because I just have a weird American flag next to me.
Luckily, I'm here to talk to you about how you can support our soldiers.
With my hand up, I'm like, well.
With war with blah blah blah on the rise.
It's time to support our soldiers, men.
You say women should be back in the kitchen?
You should be enlisting.
Hello, welcome to...
Welcome to being a member.
Delanash!
Ronnie time?
What do you mean, Ronnie time?
Oh, god.
Can you guys hit each other? That'd be great.
Oh, hello.
Hello, nice to see you there.
Fuck off, bro.
No.
I'm dead.
Close, close.
Yeah, I need to kill at least one of them and I'll be golden.
All I have to do is run away from the other one.
Okay, the sickle one is better to get up and close personal to, in my opinion.
You...
Are these the main bosses of volcano manor? I can't remember.
Oh, this has been fun.
Like I just flop on the ground.
No!
You fucking asshole, he's like, my turn.
Come here, you.
You're mine.
Ha!
I don't quite understand that.
No!
I'm just getting passed around.
Like I'm at a fucking frat party, what the fuck is this?
This is stupid.
I'm mad, but I still got jokes.
What frat party was this?
I've never been to a frat party.
This is just a joke.
I never went to a actual college, I just did online college.
Because it's so easy.
I was working on getting my computer science degree.
I am stuck.
No.
I'm scared of being caught.
Do you see how he tracks me?
I need to heal.
I need to heal again.
I need to fuck.
No, I never finished school.
It's just a pain.
I didn't like it.
I didn't like school.
If anything, I'm considering going back.
I didn't mean to press that, but it's fine.
And if anything, making my major psychology or something.
Or just a liberal art.
Just because, although, like, I would have made really good money had I stuck with it.
But I'm like, I enjoyed coding.
I wanted to be, I wanted to be do front end development.
Because I really love just making things pretty.
Now.
Can I get out of here?
If I had lightning, this would be great.
Yeah, happy pork.
Is the ash of war too much to them?
I'll try it.
I didn't try it yet.
I don't think they're kind of like doesn't really matter with like with magic.
I tried throwing rocks at them.
I didn't really do anything.
I know I never, ever use lightning unless it's against these motherfuckers.
For everyone, my career for it is mostly high school grads that just buy a school.
Yeah.
I just like, because I was in school before I got into the dealer.
But I was just like, I didn't get out of school because of dealer.
Don't don't get it twisted.
It was just that I was already a thing on my mind.
Oh my fucking God, bro.
Please.
A camera lock dude.
I need to not lock my camera.
But I was already planning on leaving and then kind of, because I had already taken a break for like two months of school.
And then I was just like, you know what?
I don't care anymore.
I have plenty of time to go to school anytime I fucking want.
I was thinking, like let's say like a bazillion years from now when the dealer isn't around.
I was thinking, because you know how like, you know how like psychology is very, very important.
There is no true fucking HR in a Corpo.
Mental health's important.
I was wondering if I could market myself as a psychologist for VTubers.
And be, oh my God, I'm going to die.
And be like a manager, a psychologist sort of thing.
I feel like that would be a very sought after thing in the industry.
What the heck did you back up?
Whoa.
Open your little mouth.
Let me jump out.
Oh God, hello.
Oh God, how are you knowing where I'm jumping?
Oh God, I was hoping you would get stuck behind them so you didn't roll me down.
Because I'm very in tune with people's emotions.
And I love, love, love, love psychology.
And just really finding out like the how's and why's, like why our brain makes specific decisions and kind of how to work things out in a healthy way.
And because I do have a management background at my last job, I feel like,
like let's say, let's say like three years from now or whatever,
Strawny anticipates us to stop having gents.
Maybe the fourth year I decide to be, I comment on as a talent manager instead of a talent, you know?
I think that'd be cool.
Because I'm trying to think of long term.
You can't be a VTuber forever, sadly, I wish I could.
And I think that would be pretty violent because there always will be VTubers.
Like I don't, that won't go away.
But I think it would be cool.
Oh my God, please.
Just give me a chance.
But it's like I do have this approach ability.
I do have this, like I can be professional.
I want to be.
I am good in terms of like, I'm good with networking.
I'm good at connecting with people.
And I feel like I would benefit a lot of like future YouTubers in no way.
And especially because I've been part of the industry.
Again, this is years and years and years and years into the future.
Because again, I want to make VTuber my full time job right now.
It's essentially is.
And so I think it would be pretty cool to do something like that in the future.
Like to, or like be some sort of social media management, which I never really anticipated for myself before.
Maybe I'll take a like communications course or something.
Unironically, you'd be a great mental health professional.
I don't know why, but hearing that is just really funny.
I don't know why it's just funny to me.
Unironically, VTuber, that looks like a Muppet right now, you'd be a really great mental health professional.
Yeah, exactly.
So that's why I'm like, okay, after the three gents, because I want to be there.
I want to be there to help stick out.
Maybe the third gen, I help mentor.
I love being a mentor.
I love teaching.
I love that sort of stuff.
Oh, hello.
Hi.
Why do you get to clip through each other?
That's not fair.
How did you kill me?
Oh, I thought I was, I never got them in your hitbox.
You can see the little sneaky poos.
There.
Oh, right, it's a little air box.
A lot of conversations with my sex Muppet.
It really helped me.
My psychologist brought up how after I confided them that I wasn't comfy talking to a person, I would honestly be the most helping thing.
Oh, really?
You think so?
That's cute.
Like, I'm very in touch with my mental health.
I mean, just dropping a dookie behind me.
Oh, fuck.
I can't get out, guys.
I'm really in touch with my mental health.
I see it therapist.
I think mental health is very important.
Even if you don't really think you need one, it's always good just to have somebody like every once in a while.
Like every few months or so.
In fact, I need to message my therapist back.
She just came back from vacation.
It's important to like have somebody bounce off of this like kind of an unbiased third party.
Kind of help you untangle the yarn that is your mind, you know?
Coming for you, bro.
I wish I could get you stuck on something.
I'm dead already.
Guys, I don't know.
This is so annoying.
This might be a beat-off stream thing again.
Yeah, outside perspective.
I've also worked with psychologists and practitioners.
I just find mental health to be super, super necessary.
Especially there's not a lot of people that have a focus on mental health that is in regards to people who are social media influencers.
It's a whole different ballgame.
You're in the spotlight.
You are dealing with a different sort of hatred, different sort of comments, different sort of pressure.
And like you can ask the other girls, I help them work through their shit all the time.
Not that they have a lot, but just like if they're having a tough time, they talk to me, you know?
And I can either listen or give you a solution, whatever you want.
Yeah.
The only person who can put me down is myself.
Therapy stream answering mental health related marrows would be really cool actually.
If I would do that, just because that's a slippery slope, because I'm not a licensed professional.
I don't want you and people, some of you know would know to take my shit with a grain of salt.
Others would take it literally and just take my word as Bible, which I don't want.
That would just be a suggestion. I'm already going to die.
Can you guys stop? I need you to fuck off.
Both of you, fuck off. Both of you right now, fuck off.
You know, no one got me, no psychology major, she got me.
Um, because I've been a fair, I don't understand how people can do therapy,
personal health stuff to a stranger seems very daunting, because I've had a fair share of issues.
I talk with friends and they keep claiming I'm being taken advantage of.
Oh, because I've had a fair share of issues, like what do you mean?
Oh wait, this is two different things.
Therapy, so like I've been in therapy for a very long time.
I will not lie to you and say, you know, there's a lot of mental health issues running my family,
but thankfully my parents were, my parents were, oh shit, I'm just going to die.
Just kill me, just kill me now.
My parents were very self aware people and they were very open minded.
Like my parents are not from a generation where they think that mental health is just like get over yourself.
Which sometimes, you know, sometimes people do need to get over themselves, I won't lie to you.
So, and I've been to multiple therapists when I was a kid.
So, because I mentioned to you guys, I have OCD, I also have something called Dermatillomania,
which is kind of like almost like an offshoot of OCD, where I have this compulsion to pick at my skin,
because I feel like it's just like, it's a sensory issue for me.
I don't like when there's a bump, I don't like when there's a scab.
That's why I relate a lot to Amy when she's like, I love picking my scabs.
I'm like, oh my god, me too.
And so I went for that because my parents thought it was a form of self harm.
It is not, it is literally just almost like an OCD thing.
Thank you for the tip. Yeah, I'll fix your whole entire life.
And it took a lot. I remember my first therapist, I didn't say anything to her at all.
I was like, fuck you, you fucking bitch. I was like 14.
I'm like, don't talk to me. You don't know anything about me.
Again, I had lots of bad social anxiety as well.
I'm stuck. I'm gonna die.
I should have healed and it takes a lot of trust.
It takes a lot of repetition.
It takes, you also have to be in the right mindset to do therapy because you're not.
The thing looks so fucking funny. It's a little worm.
It's if you're resistant, it's not going to work out for you.
Just like, you know, hypnosis or whatever.
And also the therapist has to be good.
Like if you go to a therapist and they're like, and how does that make you feel like all fucking stereotypically, don't talk to them.
They're fucking stupid.
You want somebody who's going to make you think and going to challenge you and your thought processes.
And I give a shout out to my therapist for that.
She fucking bought my merch, I believe, which is hilarious because she was so proud of me because I was telling her.
She's, again, known me for years, told her how much I wanted to be a VTuber.
And then it happened and she was so proud.
She got a little key chain.
And if I'm feeling a certain type of way, if I'm like, oh, I interacted with this person
and it was not a good interaction, she's just like, why was it a bad interaction?
Why, why did you react?
Why do you think you reacted the way you did?
What may have caused you like it's just more deeper questions and like, how did that make you feel?
Because and then I also like people be like, oh, if you go to a therapist, you know, eventually have to stop because then it's then they're just taking advantage of you.
It's not working anymore.
Again, it's personal preference.
You don't have to see one.
If you don't think talking will help you that it probably won't because talk therapy is a form of therapy.
It's like there's so many other forms of therapy out there besides just talk therapy.
It's helpful.
It's helpful to kind of figure out who you are.
Again, from an unbiased perspective.
Then again, there are some very toxic therapists out there who have maybe gotten into it for your own gain.
That's why it's important to shop around.
I would say for for one because the first one I remember I went to she was just absolutely fucking off.
It was monotonous that type of like, how does that make you feel?
And she didn't take me seriously.
And I told my parents like, I don't think I don't like this lady.
And then I went to another one.
And then she kind of just felt like I felt sorry, smack my microphone accident.
I felt like she was being really condescending.
And again, I'm like 14 and I am aware that someone's patronizing me.
You know, it's bad because usually when you're a kid, you're like, oh, they're supposed to be talking to me like this.
But no, it was just like, I didn't feel good.
And I felt like I wasn't getting anywhere because like I was still I was still picking my skin pretty bad.
My mom was actually like, I had a dermatologist.
No, no, I had a fucking esthetician.
It's someone who like does like your skincare and stuff like this when you go to a spa.
Oh, that's like the simplest way I can put it.
Hi, Rena.
And my esthetician was giving me more information about mental stuff and dermatolomania than my own that my own therapist was, which was so funny to me.
She's like, oh, I've seen this before.
It's very common in women.
I'm like, what?
She's like, yeah.
You know, the best thing to do is to work on your skincare rather than and then the mental health second.
Because if you can prevent the stuff from popping up and protect your skin from like accidentally getting hurt or vice versa, then you can almost fight the urge or you can wear gloves.
And I was like, this lady was pouring so so much fucking information on me.
And I was like, damn, whereas my therapist was just absolutely useless.
And now I have a new one.
Rena, what are you doing?
She's like, she's sitting on me funny.
Hi, Rena.
But yeah, do you want to ask for you?
You don't have to do it, obviously.
I went to a therapist and I kept asking questions about my daily schedule instead of the issues I faced in my life and kids for three sessions.
And I felt like that wasn't the best way to therapy.
And then you had to tell him that.
You got to tell him that.
It's literally you have to be honest.
It's hard, but you have to be if you're going to get anywhere.
Parsing your emotions into comprehensible words or thoughts seems to be quite a large part of their.
Yes, exactly.
Because like, I remember.
So like, I've told you guys, I have a lot of religious trauma.
Ever been a really religious household.
And I was, as you guys know, I'm kind of drawn to more esoteric things because they just feel better for me.
And I kind of delved into that with my therapist.
And she's like, I think you're doing this and you're doing this sort of stuff because you weren't allowed to before.
And you're feeling rebellious because you weren't allowed to rebel when you're younger.
And I'm like, holy shit, you're right.
That's the only reason I was drawn to it.
It's because it was forbidden.
Sort of like esoteric, pagan, sort of like tarot card read in shit.
Because it's like, you know, growing up like it's demonic.
And I'm like, it was an active rebellion of me participating in it.
And that's why that's that's literally why I do it.
100%.
And it took therapy for me to realize that instead of just me being like, yes, rocks, crystals, frequencies.
Yeah, psychologist is not a doctor.
There's also a difference between a psychologist, a therapist, and a psychiatrist.
They are different things.
How does this do an eczema?
Some days it gets super bad.
Taking skin, lots of cocoa butter lotion.
Yeah, exactly.
And then, yeah, with my dermatolomaniac, I had even like a sort of body dysmorphia.
Because I always felt like something was wrong.
If something was on my skin, it was very weird.
It's like those chiropractor videos where the girl starts crying from the stress release
and the doctor stops her from apologizing and crying and reassures her.
Yeah.
Like, there are things you kind of like talk about and you're like, holy shit, wait.
That makes so much sense.
It just took to talking to somebody else.
The reason why I go to a therapist and the reason why I don't talk to like friends about stuff.
Well, I do.
I do.
One of the reasons is because everybody has something going on.
You know, everybody has something going on.
You don't want to kind of dump stuff on people if you don't know.
And so I pick and choose my moments where I share things with friends and where, you know,
I just go to a licensed professional who's paid to listen to me, you know, trauma dump,
you know, because like I've been the person and I never minded this that at my last job,
everybody went to you.
Again, I was seen as the big sister.
I was seen as the person that everybody wanted me to help fix their issues or like give them advice.
Oh, God.
Oh, hey.
Let me just a little slappy slap.
Damn it.
Ow.
Raina, you're on my arm and I can't really play.
And even customers again would tell me really deep things.
Like again, I've had customers telling me like, oh, my husband passed away recently.
I'm buying this.
Remember this of him.
I'm getting this fixed because this and this happened.
I lost a kid.
This happened.
My child doesn't speak to me anymore.
This isn't that.
Or just like my co-workers personal lives.
And it was a lot, but I can compartmentalize that stuff.
But at some point, you know, it does become mentally exhausting.
And that's why it's important not to tax your friends with that stuff.
And it's also important when your friend is venting to you.
And I learned this from one of my co-workers who is talking to me about his wife.
He was just like, I love my wife so much.
She's the great, we have amazing communication and blah, blah, blah.
I don't know why I pressed that.
But he said, always ask when someone is asking you for help or venting to you if they want a solution.
Or if they want just to vent.
Because sometimes people say things to you.
Come back here.
Damn it.
Open up.
Really, he backs up sometimes.
Where am I?
Because you don't want to start, somebody's venting to you and then you just start telling them what they should be doing.
It's not going to do anything for them.
Damn, I was close for that one.
It's really not.
They're not going to listen to you because they just think you're just wordbombing on them.
Shibi, how do I recover from the trauma of recommending someone a show and they don't watch it until someone else recommends it to them?
If that's true, I'll be real with you.
They probably don't value your opinion as much as they should.
Or they want multiple people to reassure them that's the right decision and that's on them, that's not on you.
A show, by the way, now I want to know.
With that, would you add to have understanding of a person who tells you they can't help you with right now because they have stuff going on and you have to respect that as a person?
Exactly.
Sometimes I would have one of my friends come up to me and be like, hey, can I talk to you about something?
And I'm like, I'm sorry, I generally just don't have the mental capacity for that right now.
And they're like, okay, I understand.
I'm like, don't take it, please don't take it personally.
I have my own stuff going on.
Please tell me in like a day.
And then I got you.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, Rena, you're on my arm and I can't move that well.
I'll take the first answer.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Do you want someone to talk to you?
Someone to vent to?
Yeah.
I think the second venting versus finding solutions is something that drives my mom up the wall when I try to help.
Like, and I, and I had to tell my parents that too.
Because again, like, you're still your parents, you're still like their kid and whatever.
And I remember I would talk to my mom and my mom would just try to give me advice.
And I'm like, that's not, I just want to talk to you right now.
You know, I don't want, I'm not looking for advice.
I know what I'm supposed to be doing.
I just need to talk about it.
And then when I trust that to her, she then she started to really, really listen to me a lot more and then our relationship got better.
Jesus, I can't dodge right now.
Oh, God.
I'm already almost dead.
I hate them so much.
I don't have to beat them off stream.
100% boundaries are very important.
It's a very important, but it's also like, nobody's going to know what you're thinking unless you say it.
You know, if you, if somebody slights you and you feel fronted and you start like, don't be passive aggressive.
That's not the, you're an adult.
You talk to them.
You say, Hey, I have an issue with how you approach this.
That's the type of person that I am.
If I never got into fights with anybody, one, because I was tall and people were intimidated by my height.
And two, because the moment I heard that something was wrong, that somebody was just like, Oh, so and so is talking shit about you.
This is like high school, by the way.
I immediately go to the person to be like, Hey, what's up?
Snip this in the butt.
What's going on?
So I don't fuck with that.
I don't fuck with that.
I don't need the extra silliness, you know.
Nobody does.
Nobody needs extra silliness.
Die.
Oh.
I got grabbed by the other one.
Are you serious, bro?
Oh my God.
This isn't fair.
They lining up on you.
I'm getting a train in on me by these abducer, abductor virgins.
But yeah.
Chiwi's in a yapping mood, not a slapping mood.
And boss is on the worst.
They really are, though.
Hello.
Welcome in.
No one has the same sphere of knowledge.
Most problems stem from assumption.
Exactly.
And this is what, and this is kind of what bothers me about being the VTB community, because again, everything's online.
People usually talk over DMs.
And this hasn't happened to me or anything, by the way.
It's just something I've observed.
I see that so there's so many miscommunications, so much drama that comes off of things that could be easily spoken over to in a call.
And also people just taking something too far just for the sake of it, because they get some sort of adrenaline after participating in drama, you know.
And people also just like, they've been like assumptions a lot in VTB.
That's kind of to be expected, though, because you kind of, how could you not assume things, you know?
Oh, please.
I need to get them away from each other.
That's what I need to do.
Get a trainer and on you by virgins in the wild.
It has to be relic of football.
One thing that drives me nuts is when everyone has a problem that needs fixing and talk around in circles and wants to do instead of humming about it.
Very true.
Again, actions speak louder than words.
You just want to do something.
If you see something's wrong, just do it.
Just like, just act on it.
If necessary, you know, ask for permission.
If you need to be like, hey, when you have this conversation, I would like to have this conversation with you.
Are you able to have it right now?
And also know that everybody has different ways of receiving feedback.
Some people want it told to them straight.
And some people need, they can't handle that.
Like, I'm the type of person.
And me and my dad the exact same way.
Like, and my mom knew how to handle me better because how much I'm similar to my dad.
But like, so my mom is the type of person.
So if you get into, if you get into like a little scuffle, a little kerfuffle with her, she needs to talk about it immediately.
Which is what I've learned to do is actually, as I've had it, I've hit a balance with the saving it for later and talking about it immediately.
But my dad's the type of person where he needs to kind of think about stuff and come back to it.
Everybody talks and communicates differently and you, there's nothing wrong with asking a person how they communicate, you know?
If someone's just like, I would like to be very blunt with me, then be blunt with them.
If someone's like, I can't handle that and I need to think about stuff for a little bit, then respect them.
Respect their respect that.
Because eventually you'll get to the solution you need to.
Oh, fuck. I thought I was going to dodge in time.
Look at them hold. They're waiting for me.
Irina.
Perfect example. The roof is leaking. We need to fix. We have no money, so I propose you put a tarp outside the roof.
No, it's, no, it's too much money. Okay, a few months later, the roof is sacking from water damage.
Yup.
It's also like, it's a slippery slope because everybody has a different opinion. Everybody has a different solution on how they want to do things.
And it's kind of up to the group, excuse me, how they, how they want to have a compromise to fix it, you know?
Again, that's all it comes down to communication, communication, communication, communication.
This goes for normal relationships too. They'll be your parents, your friends, your spouse, your boyfriends, girlfriends, situationships.
I've learned a lot from my therapist in general because I'll ask her questions. He's very open.
And I'll be like, how would you approach someone like this? Because I'll, you know, I'll vent to people venting to me to be like, hey, this person told me this, what the fuck do I do about it?
Like one of my coworkers is being harassed by someone and I'm like, how the fuck do I approach this? And then she's like, well, go to HR and I'm like, well, yeah, but like, what else?
I wish I could parry that somehow.
Okay, I don't think I'm getting a lot of volcano mirror anytime soon. I don't think I might just get those dectas medallions.
You die the behind your time when the name seems to abduct your chats. And every problem needs an immediate resolution, but it does need a solution. Yes, a very good friend taught me that.
Oh, man, I'm crying. I'm fucking crying. I hate this muppet. Oh, why are you crying? Oh, don't cry.
You don't cry.
Person who over things in a combo. So I'm not sure how best to communicate. Just say that. Just say that. Just tell people, hey, I tend to overthink a lot.
I need you to reassure me or I need you to be very explicit with me what you're trying to say. Like I need you to really be blunt in order for me to understand because I'm going to overthink it.
Because I know I do that sometimes. Again, I'm not a perfect person. I'm not a perfect muppet.
Somebody tells me something and my mind's going a thousand miles per hour. It was a porn hour. Why do people fight over here, by the way? I'm kind of confused by that. What's over here?
Why are so many people dying over here?
I'm a little confused.
Maybe invasions. Oh, that makes sense.
I spammed buttons to break out. It's not working.
I know they're weak to electric. I don't have anything electric for them.
I could try to craft some electric shit.
My health is too low. What are you talking about? Who are you? Get out of here. Nobody asked you to speak.
Cookbook search? Yeah, I'm thinking I might need to get a lightning cookbook out of the fuck it's called.
Wait.
Can I knock it out of here? Okay, I can. Thank God.
I'm wondering if there probably isn't another way for me to get out.
What was I going to do?
I'm going to get out of here.
Gally haven't been to the plateau yet? No, because I'm going to fucking these motherfuckers for an hour or two.
I just beat Rinala.
I need to get to the fucking plateau so I can get to Radon.
But these bitches are in the way.
If they hardlocked me in there, I would brute force it off stream. Don't even worry about it. Just like I did with the worm.
But yeah, I hope you guys kind of get what I'm saying.
I like being real with you guys sometimes.
Where is the nearest lightning fucking cookbook?
I often catch astrophys when I text people and they don't respond quickly and chatting in the stream has actually been helping me get over that a bit.
That's good. That's good. I get that. Sometimes if people don't respond right away, I'm like they hate me.
I said something to her the other day and she just totally ignored it.
She hates me.
And then literally like five minutes later, she's like, I'm so sorry I didn't see this.
I'm so sorry. She's profusely apologizing.
And then sometimes our minds tend to stretch things.
You too, Shibi.
You also have to think about people have other lives. They have stuff to do. They got stuff going on.
And sometimes I'll be honest with you. Sometimes I don't feel like responding to people.
Sometimes I'm just peopled out and I just don't feel like talking.
Sometimes people will text me and I will leave them unread because I'm just not mentally equipped to talk to somebody right now.
What? Mesh bat and blast.
Get me out. Get me out. Get me out. Get me out. I'm dead.
As it doesn't work.
And again, are you like two different time zooms? Exactly. That's not a factor.
There's so many different factors.
Remember how Mercy explained she didn't think she got in.
So she messaged Stroni and she was like, oh, you're actually in.
Should you be like that?
And then it's also to talk to personalities.
Stroni's a little forgetful.
And again, also different time zones.
I'm tired of tired of doing this.
I've tried to stream until Mercy comes on.
It's not going to read into her.
I don't remember what she's doing today.
I haven't looked at the schedule. I need to work on my schedule for next week.
Happy 4th of July!
The book is in the Wyndham.
Wyndham.
Catacombs.
Is there still streaming?
Yeah, I wanted to.
I didn't even know.
I haven't looked at any of the schedules today.
I didn't see know who was streaming.
Streaming Super Mario RPG.
Send a message to my friend who's on vacation on WhatsApp today.
And he didn't answer it.
And I remembered he just doesn't have WhatsApp anymore.
That too.
It's just like...
Or people have really bad reception.
You know?
Fuck you.
I don't like you.
Why does there have to be two of you?
Maybe another play.
I'm not doing that.
Yeah, we're streaming up next to mine.
Thank you for your support, everybody.
I really appreciate that.
Um...
Yeah.
A lot of things could be solved.
If people just communicated or weren't scared to.
Then people have reasons to be scared to.
Which you know, you can't blame them for it all.
You want to just gap for the rest of the stream and you beat them off stream?
I might do that.
I'm gonna keep talking and fight them half-handedly.
Half-heartedly, but yeah.
What if I do?
Maybe the wolfies will distract them.
Because they'll be bouncing around.
Yeah.
Trying to grab the dogs.
Dogs are actually helping.
Oh.
I'm dead.
Oh, not dead.
I'm almost dead.
No!
Oh, he grabbed me.
I don't know if there's a stat spread.
Um, I'll show you in a second.
Do you not zoom in on the fucking virgin crotch?
It's kind of weird.
Am I scared to communicate?
You just suck at it.
But why?
Why do you think you suck at it?
Why do you think you suck at communicating?
You know?
Do you think, do you like stutter?
Do you think you can't form your words properly?
Okay, what can you do to fix that?
You know?
I practice a lot of shit in the mirror.
Honestly, streaming helps a lot with me talking.
Then again, I worked in customer service,
but I had to address a lot of people,
so that was also a big help.
Otherwise, I couldn't talk at all.
I was almost like a fucking slut.
I was select to mute for a little bit when I was younger.
Going back to the thing about your esthetician,
knowing more about your therapist,
I teach my doctor about HRT
and provide him with my own research in order to get HRT.
That's when you go to a different doctor, though.
You want to go to a doctor that specializes in what you know.
You have to, you cannot just stay with a doctor
because it's familiar, you know?
I had to go to many different doctors
in order to figure out my fibromyalgia diagnosis,
and I'm still fighting for that.
It's officially recognized by state shit,
just like how Nikki Ray from Idol is dealing with it.
She just finally got approved for disability and stuff,
and I'm like, fuck props to her.
I want to do a fundraising thing with her at some point for fibro.
That would be amazing.
I'm definitely going to reach out to her about that.
She said it'd be cool.
I saw your communication.
I keep going.
Sometimes I just have trouble turning thoughts into words.
Then, you know, I think to fix that,
well, not to fix it, but like to practice to improve.
Just say what's on your mind,
not to anyone in particular.
Just like talk to yourself.
I talk to myself a lot.
It would have been a year-long wait to see a specialist
going to wait that long.
But don't you want to wait for the best type of care
that you want to get?
I understand.
Obviously, I don't know your circumstance.
You 100% can't wait.
And clearly, if your doctor is willing to learn
and willing to be more open-minded about that sort of thing,
then, of course, try to push the subject,
and you did, and it worked out.
Sometimes it's not a luxury.
So I'm like, hey, it doesn't work out.
Fuck them.
Fuck them and run.
Now, I'm almost dead.
Can you like just give me just a second?
Okay, who is going to be distracted?
You are.
I'm dead.
I sadly damage my voice from being in a high school metal band.
I can't raise my voice.
It's got more painful as I got older,
and it's infuriating when people tell me to raise my voice.
I'm like, that sucks.
I'm so sorry about that.
I know, like, I would love to learn how to scream,
but, again, it does strain your voice,
and you have to really learn how to do it properly.
And that's like, you know, speech therapy.
It's hard when you damage your voice like that.
And, again, you don't want to have to keep explaining to people
the reason why you can't, you know.
That sucks.
I'm really sorry about that.
I had to go through so many doctors and specialists
for my health issues, even with good insurance.
So many doctors wanted to avoid any actual tests
to help figure out what the issue was.
I feel that's so hard.
You do not know how much money I am medically in debt
because I'm seeing specialists after specialists,
not even just for fibro,
but for, like, skin stuff, mental health stuff,
physical stuff, physical therapy.
So much shit.
So much stupid shit.
Oh, God, I should have done this earlier.
All right.
Now I'm down the road.
Hey, man.
I'm gonna kill you.
I hope you keep a good eye on me.
Yeah.
When I was younger, I always felt like I had a mask,
never saying what I was thinking,
but after shedding a few years ago,
communication is so much easier and we weren't fulfilling.
I am actually still struggling with that to this day.
I 100% mask.
I didn't know how much I masked
because growing up, again, very religious,
there was different expectations on behavior.
And so I would change my behavior so I could fit in so much.
And only, like, in the past few years, have I really realized
how much I hide, how I am.
And even, like, something that stuck out to me,
when I was starting VTubing,
is someone said to me,
I can tell she's not being herself.
I can tell she's hiding herself.
And then my goal was to, if anything,
I should be my true self on the internet.
Nobody knows what the fuck I am, you know?
So much anonymity.
I shouldn't have to worry about that shit, you know?
You know?
Alrighty.
Grab my party divide.
But yeah, and then that's why I'm working,
because I realize, like, I stim, I repeat stuff,
I have echolalia, I have a bunch of other shit.
Again, I'm no professional.
I'm not a huge fan of how some people self-diagnose,
you know, sometimes the first step in getting to an actual diagnosis
is a self-diagnosis within reason, of course.
The people who go on and say that they have fucking alters and DID
piss me the fuck off, because it takes away
from the people who actually have the issue
and makes them seem less serious.
That is one of my least favorite things.
I think they have some, it's a pet peeve of mine.
As someone I have worked in human services,
I took care of adults with mental and physical disabilities
and behavioral issues, and people pretending to go
what people go through as a little quirk pisses me the fuck off,
because they have no fucking idea.
They have no idea what the fuck I work with.
One of my people I took care of had schizophrenia.
She was one of the sweetest people in the world.
She passed away recently, it was really sad.
I still have a playlist I made around my phone.
It's time to get a little emotional and think about her.
And then people just pretending to be quirky
with schizophrenia and stuff.
They're like, oh yeah, I talk to people.
There's people there.
I'm like, are you fucking stupid?
You have no idea what people struggle with.
I feel like I'm a lot like myself now.
My alter is minor in internet celebrity, oh brother.
It's like, no, you're just weird and you have a tulpa.
It's that kind of stuff.
That's why I'm very wary.
People be like, oh, my chat will joke when I was written up
that I was autistic and that I have ADHD.
And I'm like, no, I don't.
And now I'm reconsidering.
I don't have autism.
I know I don't fucking have autism.
But now I'm reconsidering if I have adult ADHD.
And I'm just like, huh, I do experience a lot of these symptoms.
I thought they were OCD related, but they're not.
Maybe I should look into that.
There's nothing wrong with that.
And I'll make jokes about it like, ah, sorry, it's my ADHD.
But I also say I don't fucking have it officially diagnosed.
But I also don't make it a part of my personality.
And some people do that are self-diagnosed.
I don't like when people make labels as part of their personality.
You're so much more than that, you know?
So much more than that.
So many different other facets to your being besides your mental illnesses,
what you identify as, who you love.
Not that those things don't matter, because they do.
They're also a big part of you.
But yeah.
I have a friend in BPD.
She's such an amazing person.
Yeah.
People at BPD have a bad rap.
I'll be honest with you.
I had a former friend of mine that had BPD.
And she blew her whole entire life up, which was sad to see.
It was really tough watching her blow up her life like that just for attention.
Because she wasn't getting the help that she needed.
She wasn't seeing anybody.
She wasn't seeing a specialist.
That's the type of thing you need to see someone for.
She didn't.
And she, you know, ruined a lot of friendships.
I had to disengage with her because I supported her on something.
Then, you know, it was all just for attention and it really sucked.
This was a deep issue.
But they are amazing people when treated.
When you're properly medicated, you're taking care of yourself.
That's so important.
I miss them truly.
And people, but also there's another thing of people who use their mental illness as an excuse for bad behavior.
I think I have like a, I took like a picture of a quote.
I forget how it goes, but it was just like, just, yes, it can contribute to it, but you can't.
Having a mental illness doesn't make you a shitty person.
That's how you handle it or something like that.
If I'm in here, pretend to have mental disabilities for pity points and Perky dealing with them gave me so much trust all the time.
Yeah, definitely.
True.
I get the sense that folks who self-diagnose these conditions just seek their feeling of importance through it.
It's also just like, it's a sense of belonging.
Excuse me.
It's a sense of belonging because you see it a lot on like social media.
People want to be a part of something.
Want to be proud of something.
They want to feel included.
They want to feel in a group.
There's nothing wrong with that.
But it might be the detriment of others that you proclaim that you're something that you're not just so you can feel like you need to fit into a more quirky label, which is unnecessary.
You know, especially with kids, kids feel like the kids are so pressured to feel like they have to fit in.
I know I like for one of my and also you just sometimes you do it just to be liked by like if you if you look up to someone or if you admire someone or you want to be friends with someone, you'll try to relate with them.
And so sometimes you might kind of try to adopt their personality traits or things that they, you know, struggle with so you can have that common ground.
I didn't find out I had ADHD until last year.
I explained a lot.
Yeah.
MPPD can be life ruining if you don't properly get help.
Truly sad.
Very true.
A lot of things can be a lot of things can be life ruining if not properly treated.
That's why it's so important to be on top of your mental health.
That's why, again, self-diagnosing is important in certain contexts.
If you think you're a danger to yourself or others, seek help.
100%.
Self-destructive behavior is always so sad, especially when you know how somebody is when they're not manic.
They're just kind of like balanced and they, you know, plateaued and normal, normal tempo or whatever.
Only people realize that simply asking for attention is not a bad thing.
That's true.
It's like it sucks though because there's always people that will like respond negatively to anything that you say.
Like I totally respect your opinion if you don't agree with me with anything I've just said for the past like two hours.
That's totally fine.
But then somebody might be like, hey, I would like some attention and someone would be like, oh, so you're just a fucking pick me or something.
Like I'm just giving an example.
So somebody that always like do that and that's where it gets tricky.
There's, oh, there's sometimes people are negative to be negative.
That's why trust and, you know, having your guard up is important some of the time.
You want to be careful, protect your feelings first and foremost, you know.
I just thought of the marina and the diamonds.
Fucking lyric.
Don't wear your heart on your sleeve.
Wear it on your cheek.
Look at the marina and the diamonds.
These are scenes for that goth emo punk.
Now it's I have DID, I have ADHD.
I am this form of this identity.
It's very interesting how people, that's such a, that actually just brought something to my attention.
It used to be like clicks in terms of, yeah, goth emo punk, jock, popular, nerdy, artistic, like it was that.
And now it's something else.
It's become more innate personality traits that you don't outwardly show your, it's your inside now.
That's so interesting to me.
I just realized that.
How, how now that's how groups are formed.
Because nobody cares anymore.
Like I'll see like, like my cousins, like my cousin, my little cousin, he plays soccer.
But he's also a big nerd.
He's also really good at academics.
He's less Pokemon.
Someone's car alarm is going off outside.
But he'll still hang out with like other nerdy kids or like the super, like, he'll sing out with the artistic kids.
Like that doesn't matter anymore.
Which is kind of cool.
Because now it's like, it's all chopped up to now you bond with people who have shared your same like headspace kind of thought process.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Everything can become a little easier when you stop and talk 100%.
Golf is just not a scene.
It's a lifestyle.
I feel like people aren't self diagnosing as all these things though, just certain internet circles 100%.
Yeah, it's not like, I don't see a people's life self diagnosing quirkly as BPD.
It's really, it's like, what, what is the fad?
And I would say, honestly, that's like, that's ADHD now.
That's why I'm wary to say if I have that or not, because I don't want to seem like that.
Because I don't know, I'm not officially diagnosed, you know, I'm not trying to do it to fit in with people.
I figure like, get the right medication so I can get shit done.
Because sometimes like for me, I only seek a diagnosis or I seek to understand a diagnosis or symptoms if I feel like it pertains to me.
Like, I personally feel like right now my medication isn't working in terms of my attention span.
I cannot focus sometimes, unless I'm really interested in something.
That's why I can stream for long periods of time because it's B2B is my special interest.
But if I have to do like housework, I'm procrastinating.
I'm also, I can't sleep because my mind keeps going.
It's going boom, boom, boom, boom.
I can't even, I'll be doing certain things.
Certain things bother me.
I have some sensory issues and I feel like I've never really noticed that before.
You know, my parents told me to get over it or that I'm being dramatic or something.
And that's, and then I'm like, oh, you know, maybe I need to look at my medication.
Maybe I need to look at my diagnosis.
Maybe I just, you know, misdiagnosis exists, you know.
Yeah.
Following this Elden Rings theory session.
Yeah, it's really interesting.
I always like talking about this sort of stuff.
I'm very, I love talking and thinking about how people work, how society works.
I also like philosophy.
So if you ever want to philosophize, is that a word?
I am down for that.
I'm never getting diagnosed.
I got to keep everybody guessing.
I think maybe that's how I want to be.
Maybe I want, I think I might follow your example.
Yeah, when you start to notice the thing when it's like, oh, I think I do have it.
Yeah, like, it was so funny.
You know that there's like that one, there is, so I was doing, when I was Rina, I think
I was doing like a slime ASMR or something.
I forget, like an actual slime ASMR.
Everybody calm down and someone was just like, I am literally on the autism spectrum and
I think you are higher up there than me or lower than me.
And I'm like, what?
You're kidding.
And they're like, go ahead, take a test online.
I'm like, what actual fucking test is there online?
I don't believe any of that bullshit online test taking.
There is a test they use as a guideline I discovered from this person that was in my chat.
It's called the RADS or the RAS, I don't know, RADS test.
I took it, I scored like 120, which is high indications of autism.
Well, not high, more like medium indications.
That kind of made me wonder.
I'm just like, okay, should I be looking into this now?
Because I'm realizing that I do do things a little bit weirdly, not weirdly.
Actually, I'll take that back a little differently with other people.
120 plus plus.
I think it was out of 240.
So I was like, I was in the middle of the road.
It was bad.
It was funny.
I got my coworkers to do a network because I'm like, hey, let's try it.
And then this one dude scored super high and he's like normally very quiet.
And he really likes music.
He doesn't really talk to a lot of people in my impulsive ass.
He scored like, I think like 240.
I just went, oh, that explains a lot in my, in my, in Salem cause she, cause I used to
work with her.
She's my one of my best friends.
She's fucking like hit me in the arm so hard and gave me such a look.
I'm like, I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to say that out loud.
Yeah, exactly.
They share a lot of traits and symptoms.
That's why I'm like, okay, maybe I should look at that.
Maybe I should look at that.
And then I'm even telling my dad to look at it.
Cause again, me and my dad are like, I'm a clone of my father.
I just have boobs and I'm not bald cause my dad is bald dude.
And I'm like, dad, I think you should consider this too.
Cause we both have like, I know my dad is learning a lot about his mental health through me cause we are so similar.
In terms of like, he is realizing he also has really bad things with change and adjustment.
And that we both like are very childlike sometimes like in goofy.
My mom was like, my mom always complains.
Sometimes she's just like, sometimes even your dad would argue like your brother and sister.
Cause my dad would just be a goofy.
And I love him for that.
He's a great dad.
I said was like he's dead.
He is a great dad.
My mom's awesome too for putting up with our bullshit.
Um, yeah, diagnosed or not, people always compare me to forest comp.
I didn't know what they meant until I watched it.
Oh, but he's such a sweetheart though.
Such a sweetheart.
I'm so thankful.
So like, again, I, like I mentioned, I worked in human services.
Um, did that for six years.
And I've also had been growing up around like the disabled population for a long time because my dad worked in the industry.
And so like one of my best friends growing up was literally a woman who was at her time at the time was I believe in her late.
No, not really.
Yeah.
Her late twenties.
She had the mentality of like a 13 year old that we would hang out all the time.
It was great.
And it just normalized it for me.
Like that, you know, people have different stuff going on.
And like there are people like, again, I told you, like I worked with somebody that gets schizophrenia.
She was there at the time too, because I worked at the same place my dad did.
And there are folks who had like, you know, different behavioral issues, autism, Down syndrome.
And so kind of just normalized it for me.
And I was kind of just like under more understanding and I'm very thankful for that.
Very thankful for that.
Because I know some people don't know how to act around that population.
You know, they're, you know, they're just like, you know, experiencing a little bit differently.
Ow.
You guys saw that.
You guys saw I jumped out of the way and it still grabbed me anyways.
That's so funny.
How the fuck did that clip through them?
These are unique in their own ways.
Anyone to understand that? Exactly.
That's why I'm a very kind of open-minded and accepting person.
Yeah.
They're cheating. They are cheating.
I swear to God, they're cheating.
They have hacks.
They're clipping through shit.
One of them is wall hacks.
Oh, well, I'm just gonna die then.
I'll kill you.
Yes, after working with a lot of people with different mental disabilities and afflictions,
I think it really makes you approach people and consider them differently.
Of course, especially. Yeah.
I loved working there.
Again, it was very taxing.
I mostly left because a lot of my folks, a lot of the folks I worked with,
the clients I supported, they were older.
They were institutionalized when they were younger.
So they were, if you have any idea what institutions were like in like the 70s and 60s and 50s,
they were a mess.
Dude.
And it's kind of helping them through what they went through.
It's pretty hard.
And then another thing was they were older.
So they're passing away.
So it was really hard because I had grown up with a lot of them.
My dad would take me to work with them.
I would like sit in color while he helped them out just like,
because it was an art therapy place as well.
That was art therapy.
That's also where I love to draw.
My dad used to trick and joke with me.
He's just like, oh, you thought you were, you thought you were helping them out.
The clients, you were one of them.
I was like, my dad was like gaslighting me to think I was disabled for the longest fucking time.
I was fucking.
My mom was so mad.
She's like, why are you talking to that?
Yeah, no, I was, it was, it was tough seeing the people that I had grown up knowing pass away.
But it was really also nice to kind of give back and take care of them.
He literally shot her island me.
Streaming is my therapy.
It really is.
Again, I guess just get to talk.
Streaming is very good.
Again, my therapist was on vacation.
So it was tough not being able to talk to her when Fia has been, not Fia.
Reina has been, I'm so used to Fia being sick that Reina is sick now.
I'm so used to talking to her about like what's going on with like my cats and stuff kind of sucks when she was around.
But you know, everybody needs a fucking vacation.
Are you kidding me?
I heard people multiple yapp all the time about how much they hate their lives.
Jesus Christ.
And I know.
And one of my friends, I recommended to her and we obviously there's like client confidentiality.
She doesn't tell my therapist is telling my friend talks to her about, but I talked to my friend, obviously.
And I'm like, damn, if I had to be her therapist, oh my God.
That can be hard.
My grandmother passed away from brain cancer the other year and you're really, but I'm so sorry about that.
That's very hard.
Loss is extremely difficult.
Very extremely difficult.
I'll be honest with you.
I haven't experienced knock on wood.
Watch my like grandfather die like three days or something.
I haven't experienced a lot of like immediate family loss.
Although my I'm actually my great grandmother passed away.
Literally a couple of weeks ago.
That was tough, but it was tough because I it was hard seeing my mom really worked up about it because she was super close to my great grandmother.
But I haven't experienced a lot of loss.
And so I always admire how people are strong people are people are so strong.
So strong after those things.
And sometimes they're not and that's okay.
That's why there's other people there to lift them up.
That's why it's important to have a support system so that you don't feel alone in the situations.
Oh, baby.
I don't know why I ran in here.
Yeah, everybody I'm gonna I'm gonna recommend a book to you.
This is my favorite book.
One of my favorite books.
Where is it? Where did I put it?
I'm very nervous because I'm wondering if I gave it to someone to borrow and they never gave it back from work.
And I will hunt that person the fuck down.
My mom wrote something for me.
It's very important to me.
I'll read you what my mom said.
So
Now maybe I'll do like a
I'll do a stream where I read this to you because I although I start I'll start fucking crying.
But it's called and this is also like an Apple TV movie that they made into a movie.
It's called the boy the mole the fox and the horse.
What are you doing?
And it's full of really sweet quotes.
It's by Charlie Mackenzie or Mackenzie.
Very beautifully illustrated.
It's very unique like sketchy painted watercolor art style.
You can just Google it and you can see some of the quotes in there.
They're very reassuring.
Anytime I'm feeling very, very down.
I'm late.
My voice is shaking because I love this book so much.
And every time I open to a page, I want to cry.
Oh yeah.
My mom dated it.
It was March 2021.
I don't know.
I think it was during COVID and I think I was just having a tough time with the isolation.
I've literally bent so many corners in this book pages because there's so many good quotes.
There's so many good quotes in here.
But I highly recommend it.
A member stream.
Maybe.
I'm sorry.
I just read about my mom row and I'm trying not to.
I'm actually fine, but I'm trying not to get worked up.
Okay.
For redacted for she be the mole is very wise.
I folded over corners of this book, which I hope you read from time to time when you're happy, when you're sad, when you feel alone.
Remember, love always brings you home and I love you always, mom.
So anytime I'm sad, I read that.
I highly recommend the book.
So sweet.
My mom is very sweet.
And maybe we'll watch it together for a watch along.
That'd be cute.
No, I'll just be crying the entire time.
I can't do that.
Like that.
Literally that book and that movie give me a Pavlovian response where I literally cry.
Like I'm tearing up right now and I'm okay, but I'm literally tearing up.
I'm looking at my mup itself with the American flag next to me.
I'm dead.
I'm your dad too.
Call me daddy.
Who's your daddy?
Actually, I need to think of what to do for a member stream next week.
Okay, let me, I'm done with this for now because that's pissing me off.
I'll do this.
I'm probably going to play this tomorrow by myself.
I will probably play a lot of this off stream.
So you might, I might be redone off stream.
I don't know because I'm not going to be able to wait and want to get to the DLC as soon
as fucking possible.
Crying the whole time would just be average.
So I need to watch along.
Porfin cries over there.
Yeah.
Wasn't she crying?
I like, oh no.
That's Sarah.
That's Sarah was reading me when I was about to end.
I can chat a little bit longer.
Crying, watch along.
Let me turn this fucking music down.
Is that a Muppet?
Yeah.
You got a problem with this Muppet?
You want to shmup it with this Muppet?
Welcome Raiders.
Chania Breakdown here at the end of John Wick 4.
I don't know why she was crying at John Wick besides the first movie.
I get it.
I cried during the first movie.
But why was she crying during the other movies?
I can't remember what happened at the end of 4.
4 wasn't Parabellum, was it?
It was, that's, she cried so much.
Chania's an emotional person.
Welcome Raiders.
Hello, Sarah.
I want to shmup it with the Muppet.
Of course you do.
You can shmup it with this Muppet anytime.
Anytime, Sarah.
Mercy pulled a U today and came into the call and was being really funny.
She scared the crap out of me with a little Atomaton.
Atomaton?
Pull up.
YouTube studio.
We're just going to gap.
We're just gaping.
We're just hanging out.
Oh my God.
The screen's so bright.
Oh, I hate it.
There we go.
Now it's better.
Sorry, I'm asleep.
Sorry, I'm not asleep.
Hello.
Okay.
It's so weird seeing my model after a while.
Whoa.
Excuse me.
Your progress today?
It's time to say goodnight.
Good night.
Excuse me.
Your progress today?
It's time to say goodnight.
Thank you.
Thank you for coming by.
There she is.
Oh, she be.
Yeah.
I can, um, I can, hold on.
I can hold it up like I am controlling the Muppet.
I'm up.
It's actually controlling me if anything, just to, just to say.
I'm trying to make this look as realistic as possible.
Also cover my boobies.
Now I look at the Muppet when you talk.
All right.
I'm taking them up on off.
I forgot.
I need to send PNGs to people that I'm collabing with.
All right.
I'm gonna take some pictures real quick.
Don't, don't mind me.
I'm just going to take some pictures.
Which one is that one?
Perfect.
Taking selfies.
What a terrible day to be a Muppet fan.
Silly or menacing.
Okay.
I can be, I can be silly menacing.
How do I, this looks terrifying.
Do I look silly and menacing to you?
I don't like that.
Let me take this off.
It's what, it was so funny.
There, these were like, I think these were like bonus expressions that like the artists
just like left.
And then every group is going through.
She's like, why does everybody have this face?
That means all of us have this goofy face.
What the fuck?
I accidentally winked.
I was like, what the fuck?
That's better.
Let me do a normal face.
Oh, guys, it's so hard being a VTuber.
I have to take selfies.
Lippies aren't closing.
Sometimes VTube Studio think my lips are like how my mouth is open.
So like my mouth is closed right now, ready?
And it thinks my mouth is open.
She really said, oh.
Can't wait for Tan to talk a little bit.
I know, me too.
I can't wait.
I think I'll feel even more like myself than them, Tan.
You're so beautiful.
Thank you.
Sheepie's lips.
Which lips were I talking about?
Were I talking?
Fuck, never mind.
I'm getting overtired again.
I feel like I want to take one more picture.
I want to selfie.
I'll do one with my cute mouth.
Maybe I should look the other way.
Cool.
It's always good to have a lot of PNGs on hand, you know?
Always good.
Maybe the ropes are back.
You need to go back.
I know I'm restraining myself.
I'm calm.
Let me throw in some music.
I'm going to my bedroom.
We're going to my bedroom.
I know that's too fucking loud.
I don't know why.
Okay.
Oh.
I should just put a Muppet.
I should just send people who are asking for a PNG.
You just my Muppet self.
That would be terrifying.
I can't even see the one who they picked.
There we go.
That's a lot of multiple.
I'm going to tell you so huge.
I should have asked mommy to get me a thing where I can put my hands on my hips.
I think that would be, and I can just power stance.
Oh, hi, Tomo.
Did you win?
I was really about to look at your DMs.
What is this?
I'm secretly responding to Tomo.
Tomo's cooking, by the way.
You guys have no idea what she's cooking.
She also sends me a TikTok that I can't watch right now.
Wait, can I watch it right now?
Can I watch this to cut?
Oh, my God, me.
Oh, my God, they're so African.
I love it so much.
They just remind me of my aunties.
I don't know if you guys can hear that, but it was funny.
It was very funny.
Can't wait to see it's cursed.
My free page is built brick by brick for my friends.
All right, well, I guess I'll read mercy.
Let me see.
Oh, holy crap.
Where?
I can't find YouTube, please.
Where am I?
Oh, it's under this.
Oh, bad.
Oh, Aimee's opening memberships.
Well, when I said I would already read mercy, but I want to read Aimee.
Oh, no.
I could not drum off so many friends streaming.
What do I do?
I love Aimee, but I love mercy too.
I wish I could split a raid.
Well, I told Mercy I would read her something.
But go see Aimee as well.
She's opening memberships.
I love her.
She's so sweet.
We were talking today because we're going to do a collab soon with some other girlies.
Question harder than the Dark Souls boss because I love so many people.
There's like five people streaming right now that I wish I could rate all at the same time.
Just split you all like 25, 20 people.
You go there.
All right.
Tell mercy I say hi.
Just say all you got to say is surprise and then you just say like a funny noise.
Just be like, that's what she did to me.
I want to bed though.
I'm knocking out because I've been streaming since two.
Holy crap.
I started streaming nine hours ago.
I just looked at my own thing.
What the hell is wrong with me?
I'm really a product.
I'm really my mother's daughter.
I can't even fucking talk.
How do you type a bunny noise?
I don't know.
Go bunny noise.
Bunny noise.
You can just be like bunny noises and asterisks.
I'm so tired.
I don't even remember how to end stream.
Okay.
There we go.
I'm like, how the fuck?
I'm so like Elden Ringbrained right now.
I'm just like, huh?
What's happening?
I was going to talk to Strani.
I want to ask you that.
Yes.
I know I'm on my end extreme, but I'm going to talk to you on my next screen.
Help me convince Strani to do a cover of, um, wait, what's the song called?
The song from the Lord of the Rings that Ed Sheeran sings.
I see fire.
Yes.
I want to do a cover of I see fire with Strani.
Convince her to do it with me.
I haven't asked her yet, but I will.
Also, my goal XLR came in.
Thank you.
I'm going to put that together.
Together.
I can't talk at all.
Oh my God.
I'm so tired.
Um, I'm going to put that together tomorrow.
I'll see if I can do some funky shit because I was waiting for that so I can do, um, reverb
a lot easily for, for karaoke.
So maybe member stream will be karaoke.
Hmm.
Why are you claimed if I do that though?
Or should I do an archive?
How do I, I don't even know how that works.
I don't know how YouTube works.
Um, but anyways, uh, stay beautiful, stay gorgeous, stay you, stay amazing.
I hope you enjoyed our chat tonight.
I know I enjoyed it.
Um, again, if you didn't agree with something that I said, you're totally entitled to that.
And, you know, you can disagree.
I still love you.
No, I don't.
I didn't say that.
You smell.
You stink so bad.
God damn.
Take a shower, bro.
Jesus Christ.
My harem smells.
Anyways, I'll see.
What am I doing tomorrow?
Am I streaming tomorrow?
How am I doing?
Am I doing Hades or ASMR?
I still didn't fix my fucking 3DU.
Whoopsies.
Anyways, I'll leave you with that.
I hope you have a good time.
What?
I don't even know what I'm talking about.
Just, let me just turn off my microphone and stop, stop talking.
I'm tired.
Oh my God.
Good night.
Don't let the sheebie bite.
Heehee.
Oh yeah, happy 4th, bye.